foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday October 17th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
nearly a year ago Mark Zuckerberg CEO of
what was then called Facebook made a big
announcement at least for the company I
am proud to announce that starting today
our company is now meta the shift from
Facebook to meta was Zuckerberg's way of
saying hey we're all in on the metaverse
as you may know the metaverse is a
digital realm you can enter through a VR
headset or using augmented reality on
your smartphone or even just a web
browser a lot of people have called it
the next evolution of the internet
so how have things been for meta since
the big Rebrand a year ago apparently
not so good
that's according to the company's own
internal documents which were reviewed
by our Tech reporter Megan barbrowski
who joins me now Hi Megan thank you so
much for coming on the show yeah thanks
for having me so let's first start with
the metaverse if I've never been there
tell me how do I get there what do I
need how much does it cost yeah so
there's a bunch of different metaverse
throughout the internet and this is
basically like each company has their
own basically online world that they
call the vetiverse and So Meta has a
bunch of different apps but the main one
is called Horizon worlds so you have to
buy these virtual reality headset for
about four hundred dollars and once you
set it up get into it there's this one
app called Horizon worlds which is
primarily used to socialize with other
people and meet other people and it's
composed of like a bunch of different
worlds that people are making and you
can visit these worlds and so I spent
some time in there for our story and I
mean a lot of these were worlds are
empty there's not a lot of people in
them and one that I did find that had
about 20 or so people into it I was you
know trying to conduct an interview and
you know there's a lot going on
um there's like children running around
there's you know some people
interrupting my avatar did get harassed
so that did happen but definitely
there's a lot going on and not a lot
going on at the same time you've been to
Horizon and you said it was mostly
Barren they're just weren't a lot of
people there I mean how empty are we
talking here so there's a lot of Worlds
that have been built and less than 10
percent of them are actually visited by
more than 50 people so a lot of them
just like remained basically empty and
in addition to that we reviewed some
internal documents that show currently
less than 200 000 people are going on to
Horizon worlds so that's less than the
population of two fall in South Dakota
so I mean compared to like meta's other
apps Facebook Instagram WhatsApp like
those together are reaching more than
3.5 billion average monthly users and so
the contrast right now is pretty Stark
so they originally wanted to reach 500
000 monthly active users by the end of
the year and in recent weeks they've
actually taken that figure down and said
our new goal is actually 280 000 because
you know they're struggling to get there
any insight as to why Horizon has been
so empty based on the internal documents
there's a lot of problems with the
Glitchy technology also people have said
they can't find worlds they like they
can't find their friends the other
complaints include you know the fact
that these avatars don't really look
real they're still like a bit cartoonish
and then I've kind of more comical one
is that none of the avatars have legs
which is I think just like a point
people like to harp on and then there's
also like some people have complained
about other users not behaving or acting
badly and you know people just don't
want to be around that and what has
meta's response to all of this been do
they say we're working on this obviously
this is not a finished product this is
something that they're still developing
and it's not done and so I do think
there's some people who are in meta's
corner in that regard who are saying you
know like look this is a work in
progress but certainly I think it's
still worth looking uh how that progress
is going which has not been too great
for meta yeah I think that's a fair
point you know meta saying that good
things do take time but as you've
alluded to now this hasn't been an
instant success for meta is that a
problem for them so certainly this is
like they've said it's a multi-year
project but the question is more does
the company have time for a multi-year
project they're in a battle with tech
talk and other social media companies
right now for users they're really
pushing reels and video content and
they're you know trying to stay relevant
right now they do want to pour a bunch
of energy and investment into this
project but at the same time there's
people who kind of want to see a more
immediate payoff and are looking a bit
more short-term than maybe meta is all
right Megan we'll have to leave it there
wsj Tech reporter Megan bobrowski thank
you so much for joining us yeah thanks
for having me I'll maybe see you in the
metaverse
sounds like a plan
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Julie
Chang for the Wall Street Journal thanks
for listening
[Music]
[Music]